エンディング
はーい、帰ったぞ。
今日のバイトはきつかったぜ。
お前はまだ寝とんのか
なんどいや信じられんわ学校行きそびれてしもうた
なんで起こしてくれへんかったんや
知るかバカたり
もうあかん
おめえさんが寝すぎだっつーの
しびれまんがな
1日16時間も寝るやつがおるか
じゃあここらでちょいと勝負しに行きまよ
もう金ねえよ
俺の持ち金今20円しかねえ
やりまんな
わいは17円や
勝った師匠に2円だけあげますわ
いらねーよ、そんなもん!
ほなら、ぜんざいさんをかけて、サイコロ一発勝負といきまひょうか。
よーし。
勝ったもどうぜん!
それ行け、チッチロリー!
よーし、ピンサロだ!
はい
まず一人倒したで
本当に鉄砲でチャンスを行くのか
当たり前でんがな
このノリで勝ちまくったる
それにワイは鉄砲やられん
ちゃんと37円持ってますやん
それが鉄砲だっつーんだよ!
わいは、わいはしびれたいんや。しびれたいだけなんや。
ビビったー。静電気が。
バカ。
ちゅーす。
いらっしゃーい。
あら、豊臣くん、それにお弟子さんも。
だば!
腕まっか、ママ。
ちょうど今、天狗の台が開いたところよ。
ママさん、見損なってもろては飽きまへんな。
ワイを天狗で撃たせる気でか?
え?
ワイは、ワイは…
ワイはこうじゃしびれまへんのや!
ピンや!男はピンで勝負せな!
そうね。
ママ、ピンのタクイチかけ!
え?
ほな、始めまひょうか!
師匠、どいつもこいつも大した奴やなさそうやで。
そ、そうか?
ほんや!
ダブトンドラ1、まずまずやな。
リーチ。
ああ!そのシャーマット!
あかん。やっぱチーピンは打てへん。
ええわ、続けて。
あんた、そういうの5本だよ。
キモッタマの小さいこと言わんとき!
あ、まらん!ドラキューピン!
シャーポンしとったらキューピンドラタンって上がっとったやんけ!
こーりゃ、なかなかしびれるわー!
なんやこりゃ!
ローン!リーチはいて、はくごんに!
ローンでワイから当たるんや!
しょんぱいだからだよ。
あんた、そんなのしゃーけりゃいいのに。
その手はない。
わいは勝ちに来とるんとちゃうで。
しびれに来とるんや。
とーら見てみ。
確定単品3式、配線いまだ衰えずや。
売っとるしるしやで、ほんまに。
ここは一つだまで。
いや、待たんかい。
それよかリーチして積もったら晴れまんやんけ。
いやいや、違うで。一発にウラドラ乗れば、倍満やんけ。
こ、こりゃー。
想像しただけで、しびれてしもうたかんだ。
いいから、早く切れよ。
うりーち、かかってこんかい。
くー、なんちゅうかたさや。
アンさん、麻雀でしびれたこと、あらへんやろ。
ああ
よーし 詰まった ゴミ
何度やー
俺はこれで 十分 しびれられるぜ
そんなもん ほんまもんの しびれ あらへん
ねえ とにもかくにも 俺のトップだな
こんなんじゃーかー
うわぁ!わぁ!もっとしびれたいよ!
ビリッビリッビリッビリッしびれたいよ!
ママさん、アウトよろしく。
え?いきなりアウトって?
ちょっとまさかあなた鉄砲で撃ってたの?
ああ、分かっとらんなママさん。
ええでっか、鉄砲こそが一番しびれるんやで。
何言ってんのあんた!
ええ、ママ。この通り、お願いや。
だめ。
だったら、お前が負けたら、師匠が1ヶ月ここで、ただ働きするいうんは、どうでっしゃろうか。
それなら、いいわ。
ええ、ちょ、ちょ、ちょっと待ってよ。
もし、あなたが負けたら、豊臣くんに、お休みなしで、みっちり働いてもらうわね。
そんな。やっぱ、わいと師匠は、一心同体や。
おい、こっちで、良品の宅建てるけど、誰か入ってくんな。
え?あいつらいつの間に?
よっしゃー!わしが入るでーす!
こらこらこらこらこらこらこらこらー!
お前な!相手が誰だか分かってんのか?
大丈夫っすよ。今日のワイは負ける気がせーへんもーん。
そんなこと言ったってさっきお前…
ほらほら!やるのか?やらねーのかなー?
やりまんがなー!
大丈夫かなー?
リャンピンはやっぱええなー。
リーチ!
んーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
こりゃぁぁ!
よーし。
クーーーーー。さすがりゃっぴんや。
一つ通しただけでもピリピリきよるわ。
ふっ。鉄砲で来て、りゃっぴんで麻雀を打つ。
まさしく排水の陣や。
捨て身の戦法やで。
肉を切らせて骨を断つ。
そうや。これぞわいの生き方や。
ふおぉ。
バッコイイ!ワイ自身の生き方にしびれてもうた!
早く撃てよ、おめえ。
アホか。
来たー!
パーワンとキューワン。
比較的安全なとこ切るんはどうしろや。
マージャンは、なんちゅうても、めくりゃや!
強いな。
ホロロロロ!一発かましだった!
よっほーい!
なんだそりゃ!
三腕、靴付きの三射具、ウーピンのドラ引き、
リア運送のいいペーコー目と、変わり目が三つもあるじゃんかよ!
ワイの麻雀はこれからやでぃ!
ローン!ヒンパチ発進!
一番にシーン!
おお!ダントツトップ!
さすがワイや!
ぽん、ぽん、ぽん!
おっと、おやが相当きばっとるで。
なぁに、こっちは降りてるやあんたよ。
言うとくけど、泣き合戦やったらワイも負けへんで。
ん?
ちぃ、ぽん、ちぃ!
アホが!トップめがそんなに手を縮めてどうすんだ!
手が縮まる恐怖と圧迫感、それがワイを心から痺れらすんやで。
明日からの俺の生活も痺れるわい!
ドラムチューン!
やめろ!そんなの90%当たりだよ!
普通の奴ならこの牌は打てんやろ!
だがワイは…ワイは…
考え直せ!
痺れる牌しか打たんの!
ぽん
痺れる!
ど、どうすか?師匠、ワイはギャラリーまで痺れさせるっしょ!
ああ、心ゆくまでしびれさせてもらったぜ。
ええい、なんならつぼらんかい!
ほう、やっと降りる灰をつかんでくれたか。
いくぜ!
ああ、ちょちょちょ、やめろよ!それを切ったらマーシャンじゃなくなる!
止めといてしろ!こんなしびれるチャンスはめったにないや!
せや!
投資
こんなにしぶれて
おりゃ来い
なんやこりゃ
なんだ
賞賛本一ドラナナ数え役マンだよ
はい肩残った人は電気アンマーのサービスです
おーこれいいわ
ママさんサンキュー
向こう1ヶ月はサービスするわね
アカーン
ズガーン
しびれしびれで半年暮らす
あとの半年寝て暮らす
ああ
男命のしびれ麻雀心意気
でも懸命なあなたは決してやらないでください
腹減った
師匠 わいはもうお金のない生活に疲れました
もう少しリッチな人を探して
楽しいクリスマスを送りますやん
バイケンジ
くそー 身勝手なやっちゃ
そういえば今日はクリスマスイブか
最近アキナちゃんとも電話してないし
電話しよーっと
はい、はやびです
今日はとっても大切な待ち合わせがあって
留守にしています
ご用件のある方は発信音の後にメッセージをどうぞ
大切な待ち合わせ
メリークリスマス
さあメリークリスマスマージャンやっと
ほらサクサク起きる
ほらほらとっといくだよ
レッツォホイッスォホラサッサ
ズガーン
あんだ、トヨトミ。いつにも増してだらしねえじゃねえかよ。
何かあったのか?
心配してんだぞ。
あー、なんて俺たちは優しいんだべ。
おら、これでも舐めて元気出せや。
ロロップ!ロロップだ!
あら、お口開けてごらん。
今度のは何味かな?
わー!いちごの味がする!
幸せそうだな
俺たちは本当にいい仲間だな
ということは、もうちょっと奴を不幸にしても構わねえってことだな
まあ、言い方変えるとそうなるぺよ
イヴの夜まで麻雀するのやっぱ嫌やな。
うなぐだゆでね。おめえの番だよ。
口いらないちゃい。
トヨトミ、おめえ、手の内全部ロロップだべ。
まだ全部じゃないようだ。
わがこいつにねだよ。きゅうぴんきゅってりち。
わー!ヘッドロンプがいっぱい!
早く切れ、コンガケ!
これ!
ローンだよー!
リーチ一発メンチー!
はーい、みんな!サンタさんですよー!
あら?
サンタだ?
あ、その人雑誌で見たことあるぜ。
たしか、麻雀でこの30年もの間、一度も上がったことがないというじいさんだ。
ほらほら見て、豊臣くん。サンタさんよ、サンタさん。
ほんと?ほんとじゃよ。
そんなんでどうして麻雀なんか続けてるの?
好きなんじゃよ。
え?
わしゃ、麻雀が心から好きなんじゃよ。
だからこうしてイヴの夜にはサンタになって
全国のツカンコのために回ってくれてるのよ
世界一つかないわしを見れば
きっとそれが若者の自信につながるはずじゃ
すなわちわし自身が君たちへのプレゼントというわけなんじゃよ
おーじいさんやるべやるべ
おもしれえサンタだ
でもレベルはたけえぜ
知らんぷりっと
サンタあんた本当に上がったことをねえだか
天に誓ってするはない
あんましえばれることじゃねえだよそれって
さすがサンタすごいクズハイだわ
今宵はハイパイがいいな
いつもはウーシャンテンだが今日はなんとスーシャンテンだ
いるぞ、いるぞ。近くにいるぞ。強力なツカンコがよ。
こいつは違う。こいつも違う。
こ、こいつだ。
な、なんというツカンコなのじゃ。
ツカンポの鼻の亡霊が彼の肩に重くのしかかっておる。
チェーペンキッドリーチだ。
キャーこんなひどい手配なのにアンパイがない
メリークリスマスだよ
俺にも俺にも
ジングルベール
ドラップ
もうせっかくとゆとみくんのためにサンタさん連れてきたのに
何やってんのよ
どれどれ
なんだいい手じゃない
どうしたの
このわしが
てっぱった
まさに
7年ぶりのことじゃ
そう、あれは7年前のクリスマスイブのことじゃった
このわしがテンパった
まさに12年ぶりの快挙
楽しい
マージャンと若くも楽しいものよの
リーチジャドラ!
悪いな、じいさん。ベッドハンピー三色ドラドラ。
親の羽ば一番、ハンセンテド!
そして今、また…
な、懐かしの…リーチジャ…
ドラだ…
はぁい!相手は一度も上がったことのないサンタだ!ここは思い切って!
頑張れよ。もしここで俺がサンタに振り込んじまったら、俺が最初に上がらせた男になっちまう。
ど、どうしたの?豊臣くん。
ふにゃー。
はぁー!
ロン、チャンタだけ。
もう、他の人の捨て牌も見なさいよ。
ね!でも、ドラのローは当たってるでしょうね!
わしゃあ、ペンチーピンじゃよ!
おお、こりゃすごい!
このわしが二連続リーチじゃ!
上がれ、上がれる気が猛烈にしてきたぞーい!
リーチ!
くそー!
こ、今度は、降りないぞー!
行くぞ!レー、チェン!
ドクターディナウォルト
リーノミどうして?なりと鬼殺スペクタクルやってんのよ?!
亂団狩A
ロンジャー!ロンジャルニーノミジャー!
サンタさん、初めてあがられた感想はいかがでしょうか?
え、いやー、まあ、上がってみると、こんなもんかなーって感じかなー。
スカルポー。
おう、そうじゃった、そうじゃった。
わしに振り込んでくれたあんたにプレゼントをあげよ。
ほれ。
うわー!ロロップだー!
ロロップ、ロロップ、わーいわーい!
-ロロップ、ロロップ、わーいわーい! ダメだわ。
すんごくダメだわ、この人。
ロロップ、ロロップ。
豊臣の声は雪の町にこだまする 太郎の屋根に雪振り積む
今日も独り寝のあなた 何はともあれメリークリスマス
川上から流れてきた大きなイーピン その中から生まれた男の子は図鑑太郎と名付けられました
次回、明けましてつかんぽ。つかんぽ昔話。きっと見てね。眠っちゃ、やっ!
ご視聴ありがとうございました
スーパースーパー
呼んでやるまんまく心
ここは三面町どころ
行くべかんきゃ
おしむそぼのせきがはだ
すぼうにぃぼうまけんぼうにぃやりぬいて
かってのびごすビールがうまい
スカット! オザカワイドチガケ!
スカッタスカーン!
スカット! スカッゾー!
ガキカメタ! ガガンガンガンガンガン!
ありがとうございました。